all right scott
scott oh where'd you grow up where are
you from original
uh right outside of nashville tennessee
a little town called columbia
and tell me about your family growing up
you had experience uh both parents they
got divorced when i was about 13. 13
dad was in vietnam
mom's school teacher dad heavy
ptsd from the war alcoholic
uh
really hammered down on us in the family
what kind of what kind of childhood was
it oh
horrific there's child abuse and then
there's torture this guy will flip out a
lot
do things like
go out just
go out into the street shoot the street
lights out
he had things that he called attitude
adjusters
it was like a leather
it was a wooden handle with a leather
strap
and like 30 pieces of
rawhide leather
and that was our disciplinary tool
from age three to
twelve and uh he would use switches with
thorns
hit us
25 30 times i remember my brother
standing beside the door just counting
how many times i would get hit
mentally
uh preparing himself for what was to
come for him
and uh
it it really [ __ ] me up it it stuck
with me till now i'm 46 years old
lot of the old man would always say pull
your bootstraps up and be a man but i
never saw him do that he still drinks
from the bottle he's born in 1946
and still drinks heavy
do you think this was a product of him
going to vietnam or i think it was his
upbringing i don't know much about my
family i don't know much about his
grandfather i know he had a family my
grandfather was born in 1900 he had a
family before
he had my dad and my brother he had two
daughters and during the depression
they the family got broken up
he had to move up north with his four
brothers to gary indiana and work for us
still
and uh then he met my grandma that was
born in 1910
and
they
lived and worked up there for us still
for 30 40 years with his four brothers
and
some of his brothers were tired out of
there and then when he retired he moved
back down to kentucky and was a prison
guard
from
bits and pieces that i picked up for my
mom i assume
both hit you know it was just the time
back then it was a hard time i'd ask my
mom like
she said when she first met him you know
them being born during 1900 1910 growing
up in the depression no electricity no
air conditioning in kentucky and
tennessee
outhouses tough people
things of that nature
i'm sure they endure a lot of physical
abuse a lot of hard times that's just
the way it was back then yeah
so you made it through high school
yes
what kind of kid were you in high school
uh skateboarder punk rocker
the abuse was
given out to everybody in your family
yes
me my brother
my first cousin my mom
my my dad and my uncle cut from the same
cloth i never really knew my granddad
because he passed away when i was like
five years old
and from what i've gathered he was a
really mean person really sadistic i've
known people i've known veterans that
have gone to the war and seen some real
horrific stuff and they're real loving
people they don't physically abuse
their families my dad would do real
sadistic stuff like he grew up on a farm
so he was raised
you know out in the woods and i
understand that you know killing rabbits
things of that nature is a part of a way
of living to survive but then there's a
sadistic part of it i remember like for
instance when i was 14 years old
we had
he lived in the country and he had um
two neighbors
and he didn't like them because they
were lesbians so he wanted to prove a
point to him they had three dogs i'm 14
years old my brother's a year and a half
older than me
the dogs kept coming on the property and
he just shot him in front of us and told
us
he shot the three dogs
and then told us he was drunk pick the
dogs up and put them in the back of the
truck and drive them up the top of the
hill and just dump them
and i told him i don't want to take no
part of that then he pointed his gun at
me
and told me like
you pick the dog up
or you're next you know and i'm 13 14
years old in the middle of the country
we're like 30 minutes from any kind of
store
so i just got to do what the guy says
you know
so that's the kind of
[ __ ] that i dealt with so i made it
up in my mind
through my teenage years that i always
wanted to live out here i was influenced
by the skateboarding and the punk rock
community i take pictures out of the
thrasher magazine put them up on my ball
and just daydream about living in
california
so when the time came
late 19 early 20 i moved out here with
just 300 in a backpack and started in
skid row
lived in a homeless shelter
got a job
at a hotel
doing night auditing things of that
nature just things to survive
when i was in high school i would i i
did do like hallucinate uh like
hallucinogenic drugs
like dxm robitussin lsd magic mushrooms
things of that nature but i never really
got into the hard stuff like cocaine or
crystal meth it was more experimental a
way to escape
a way to heal a way to like calm all
that abuse that was coming in the way i
look at it
probably my dad and his uncle had a lot
of childhood abuse and then
on top of that he went to vietnam
they'll tell him what he saw over there
so that just
probably
you know
stacked on top of it so he just came
back home a mess
you know a lot of guys come back home
from vietnam a lot of guys come back
home from all kinds of wars
but they're not at home they're still at
the war i've heard heard all kinds of
stories about their wives and husbands
going to the grocery store with the
family coming back and putting groceries
in the car and then the husband would
hear like a a car backfired like a
gunshot and just hit the ground and just
freeze
crawl under the car for two or three
hours
things like that
they
i didn't know anything about ptsd i
didn't get any kind of therapy when i
was in
my teenage years i just used drugs as
like a therapy
to escape from all that
and uh around may of 2009 my
first cousin which i think is my half
brother now i don't know because of the
family's so secretive
murdered his family
and uh ended up shooting he had three
sons he had a 13 year old son he had an
eight-year-old son and a five-month-old
baby
he uh
shot the eight-year-old son shot the
five-month-old baby shot the wife and
then killed himself fired two shots at
the 13 year old the 13 year old survived
still living today he's probably about
26 27 years old i don't have
communication with him tried to reach
out to him a couple times but
the family brainwashes him because they
know i broke away from the family i came
out here to california to get away from
all their [ __ ]
and all their brainwashing and all their
lies
and from what i understand from what i
heard through the grapevine he had
therapy for about six months after the
shooting and then
they just stopped making him go i heard
he got arrested for using marijuana and
then
my uncle and my aunt which is his
grandparents had custody of him at the
time just kicked him out of the house
and sent him with his biological mother
at the time of the murders he was living
with a stepmom
and so he goes to live with his
biological mom i hit him up when he's
like 17 years old telling i know he's
into skateboarding i told him i got a
skateboard for you
you know i'd you know like to make a
connection with you he pretty much told
me like the families told me you're
crazy i don't really want to have any
part of you so i just stepped back and i
i told myself he'll understand how the
dynamic of the family works when he gets
older and i won't intervene i won't
interfere i want to try to reach out to
him lo and behold 10 years later he's
like 26 27 he don't have much to do he's
pretty much seeing how the family
dynamic is and how they function they're
lying cowards i've tried to get a hold
of him multiple times i call my uncle
hey
uh how you doing this is your nephew he
just straight up hang up on me i'll call
my aunt she'll hang up on me they don't
want to talk to me they don't want to
face me i don't understand i've reached
out to multiple family members
i don't understand why they want to
don't want to talk to me i haven't had
anything to do with them really since
the mid 90s
whatever went down in the fam family
dynamic however traumatized they are
from what my cousin did
i can understand that but i never did
anything wrong
the blowback that i that that i hear
through the family
uh is that
everybody thinks that i'm they don't
really know me because
when i moved out here in the late 90s i
just disconnected for the from the whole
family and didn't really talk to any of
them and didn't really talk i was real
tight with my cousin we had like a
trauma bonding type thing we were tight
like brothers growing up
but after i got out here i just
disconnected and i was just in a mode of
survival and
10
11 12 years went by
and i reconnected with him about a year
before he killed his family so we had
like a year
of a relationship that was going down
and uh
and it went well
you know
still the same thing with the family
dynamic i could still see he was
struggling
with drugs and alcoholism trying to cope
and trying to heal his trauma
and then you know i i moved back to
tennessee to try to go through a nursing
program to try to get out of the streets
here to try to get out of the daily
grind to try to better myself so
i thought i'd go to nursing school so it
was around april of 2008 that i moved
back there and that's when i started to
develop a relationship with my
my cousin and we we got tight and i was
in that area for about 18 months
and i was at school one day on a
thursday we always had like a family
routine a family ritual
because he lived in florida i lived in
tennessee where we would always talk on
a sunday and we would just you know bond
like brothers and stuff and try to get
together as much as we could that's all
i really knew
and uh he called me on a thursday i
could tell something was wrong and i was
in class taking a test and i told him
hey call me on sunday like we always do
and he said okay
well that sunday came around i didn't i
never heard a phone call so i felt
something funny in my system i couldn't
go to sleep
the next morning i get a phone call
uh it was always uh like inside joke
with the family that i put the old man's
nickname and my phone as satan
because he's so mean and sadistic so i
was in the shower on monday morning and
i got a missed call from satan and i'm
like oh it's my dad what's he doing
calling
and so i called him back
he answers the phone
he says
all he says to me is this right here
oh
it's bad and i said what are you talking
about it's bad
he said
your cousin
troy
turn on the tv
and then he just hangs the phone up so i
turn on the tv it's on msnbc
cnn all the major news stations
that he killed his family what the story
that went down and
in the first week of may of 2009
and the weeks to come it went all over
the newspapers
nationwide it was in papers in seattle
it was in l.a times it was in the front
page of the paper the little town i grew
up in but this happened in tennessee
yeah and so after that i shut down
i i went my body went into shock i
couldn't eat i couldn't sleep for a week
the trauma everything
triggered again
and i just stopped functioning so that
was around may and i still had to tie my
school up
but when you get traumatized when you go
through
physical or sexual abuse as a child no
matter how gifted you are no matter how
intelligent you are
that trauma takes over and it becomes a
fog in your mind where you can't
concentrate on your studies so you start
to fall behind no matter how
intelligent you are no matter how high
your marks are in the scholastic test
that you're taking no matter how far
ahead no matter how quick you catch on
to the material
the trauma affects you
and
and it's still with me i'm like i said
i'm 46 47 years old and my whole life
story is about
how do i get rid of this trauma how do i
heal this trauma how can i help myself
and then how can i help other people
i've tried to get into other jobs all
through my 20s i would get various jobs
i'd hold them for six months to a year
and then i'd get triggered the boss
would say something that would sound
like what the
the tone that my dad would use and then
you know i would catch myself being
outside of work waiting for this guy and
and
why am i outside waiting for this guy
you know
i'd want to [ __ ] him up you know and
just
all the stuff would kick in
and i never understood that so i went
through my 20s
and to my early 30s where i would just
have like a slew of jobs where i'd hold
them six months to a year i never used
drugs i was just so traumatized i didn't
really understand what was going on and
then when my cousin murdered the family
all that kicked back in my brother
called me on the phone he told me uh
after i moved out here like i said i was
going to school in may of 2009
so it was around september
that i moved back out to la and started
over my brother bought me a plane ticket
to come out here i had 100 bucks i came
out here
checked into union station homeless
shelter in pasadena and just started my
life over it was then my brother was
talking to me on the phone and told me
he was getting a lot of counseling for
what was going on in our childhood and
he recommended that i go to a therapist
and and start getting involved so i got
involved with union station pasadena
they hooked me up with a case manager
they gave me a social worker i started
getting into therapy i started learning
that when you get abused as a child
physically or sexually it rearranges the
chemistry in your mind
and it really does
a whole number on you it it rearranges
the chemicals in your mind it rearranges
the chemistry in your body
and it really [ __ ] you up
and i had to get with therapists and had
to reprogram i had to relearn how to be
a human being again so they took me in i
lived in a shelter there for about a
year
and then they got me into a sro and i
lived in an sro around pasadena and
around downtown l.a for about five years
and then after that i got um
into a nice apartment for about seven
years
so since my cousin murdered his family
i've just been focused on trying to heal
myself from the trauma
and and figure out what the
what is really going on in my mind it's
it's a huge fog that i just had to step
back from
i i stepped out of the workforce when i
was 31 years old so i haven't really
i i started to try to build a career as
a truck driver i got my commercial
driver's license i drove trucks for
about 10 years same thing kept happening
i'd keep jobs for about six months
and then would quit and would just break
down they lay down on my couch what
what's wrong with me and then i'd hear a
blowback from the family oh you're just
a lazy piece of [ __ ] you don't want to
work what's going on i i didn't
understand therapy and stuff like that
like i said and then after my cousin
murdered his family
and after i dropped out of the workforce
i started learning from these therapists
no you have ptsd just like a war veteran
from the child abuse
of what was going on in your life so
my life has taken a turn these days what
i'd like to do
is be a pastor counsel those that are in
the streets they're addicted to drugs
that are heavily traumatized
that people that got physically and and
sexually abused and went through similar
circumstances like i did because
that
to me that's the only thing really worth
doing on this planet you can have
materials you can be
you can get your phds you can be a ceo
and you can you could do these major
things and you could have multiple
houses but
what is that really going to do to you
when your soul leaves your body
nothing
in my mind
it's the work you do the seeds you plant
into people's hearts because i believe
our souls are dwelling in these
temporary vessels
that
are temporary and everything we build in
this world is temporary like a house a
car our bodies
so the only thing that really matters is
what you're doing to someone's soul how
you're interacting with other people on
a daily basis how you're helping them
how you're putting your energy out there
into the world and what kind of person
you're being
to other people and what kind of
relationship you have with god that's
all that really matters in this
temporary world that we live in and
that's what i'm really living for today
that's great
that's wonderful to hear
what what ways did this
what you went through in your childhood
affect you as an adult i think were you
like selfish like i said i i i would get
jobs
i i never did i did drugs through high
school when i got out here i was living
on the streets
i didn't have any family i didn't have
any friends i didn't have any
connections so i didn't have time to do
drugs i just went into straight survival
mode and what the therapist has taught
me
that that was a trauma in itself being
homeless coming out here and living on
the streets so i had trauma from my
childhood then i had trauma from living
on the streets out here and just being
in raw survival mode for 10 years trying
to
just figure out what was going on and
then
in my late 20s early 30s i just shut
down one day and just broke down after
my cousin killed his family i was you
know 31 32 years old and i just stopped
functioning
and i just
it was like i became catatonic
and then that's when my brother stepped
in you have to get therapy you have to
understand what trauma does to your
system it's everything in this world is
based on energy
and when you get abused by other people
it's energy that you're taking on to
your soul to your what i call like
my jacket we all have a jacket and what
you're putting onto your jacket your
soul jacket is energy everything in this
world is based on energy and that's what
scientists teach you it's all based on
how molecules and particles vibrate
energy can be created it can't be
destroyed and you learn these things
through physics and through the second
law of
thermodynamics and things like that so
you have to look at things as a soul you
have to look at things as energy
and
that's what i'm focusing on today that's
great
how is this how have your
relationships then since you've
i don't know i've i've i've had
girlfriends it's hard to keep
relationships because i isolate a lot
and and then
like the jobs the relationships just
fall by the wayside and i end up
becoming a recluse i just isolated my
apartment so after
the murders and uh and the suicide of
the family i got a therapist they put me
on disability
and uh i'm just focusing on
how i can
utilize the gifts that god gave me
to put it back out into the community
and heal myself so i can heal other
people so before i got into hardcore
therapy i was just isolating in my
apartment still to this day it's just a
lot of isolation i just stay to myself
uh i never really had friends i looked
up to people
you know like henry rollins has a lot of
that going on he has a similar story to
me where he's kind of like a reclusive
type character so these were my heroes
growing up mickey rourke the actor
similar story a lot of physical abuse
going on and i always strive to be like
people like henry people like mickey
that had a voice that
stood back stepped back and overcame all
that abuse and and gave back to the
community
so
it's interesting that you can keep your
uh
just keep yourself together as well as
you have right with everything you've
been through right how are your siblings
handling it uh saying uh
my brother
alcoholic he's he admitted to me he
started drinking when he was about 14. i
started using drugs when i was about 14.
uh i i used drugs from 14 to 19 when i
moved out here and then i got saved
and
i i started developing a relationship
with god so that
took place of the drugs and it was god
that walked me through everything when i
first got out here like when i came out
here i had a backpack and 300 and i got
off the
the bus at the greyhound bus station
just right down the street here and you
know
my heart's pounding in my chest so hard
that i could hear it in my ears i could
feel my pulse in my ears i could feel
the pulse in my teeth and
and i'm just a kid with a backpack and i
don't know what to do so what do i turn
to i didn't turn to drugs so i just
would say quiet prayers to myself like
god help me get through this and i would
hear a small voice in me
talk to me and guide me through these
things you don't know these streets you
don't know any people here but i do i
built these streets i
i know all the people that you need to
go to and that voice which is god guided
me to these people that i needed to go
to got me a job got me an apartment and
that's what i've used as my navigation
throughout my adult life instead of
picking up drugs and you know
escaping through drugs i just
escape into the holy spirit i get my
healing
resting in the holy spirit it's when
people
do crystal meth when people take a shot
of heroin you feel this warm being come
over you like someone's hugging you and
it's love and that's what god is god is
love so when you accept the holy spirit
into your heart the holy spirit comes
into you and gives you that same feeling
that drugs do that warm feeling so you
don't need drugs so a lot of my
ministry a lot of my therapy that i do
with people is
you know it's it's easier said than done
but if we could teach people not to take
the drugs and to just take the hits off
the holy spirit i think the world will
be a lot better place
but
it's it's a real hard dynamic and as
i've talked to you on the phone a lot of
people that i counsel will always blame
god well if there's a god
how can god allow you to go through all
the child abuse that you went through
how could god allow the holocaust to go
on how could god allow all the people to
be living on the streets and murdering
people all the time but it's not god you
got to understand that god created
angels and you have to understand the
history of creation
and how that all came about and where
human beings are in the standpoint of
that and how angels became jealous of
human beings and how god views human
beings above angels and to me and to a
lot of people that study the bible
that's the devil got jealous of human
beings and that's what kicked off a war
in heaven and he convinced a third of
the angels up there
to come down with him and get away from
god and then they became
cast out of heaven and into this world
and they became the rulers of this world
so would you say that you're able to
find happiness at this point
through through god yes through the holy
spirit i've always been able to find
happiness but it's still a struggle i
still have that
trauma that energy on my jacket what
kind of emotions do you go through
a lot of frustration a lot of
overwhelming emotions a lot of
depression they say depression is just
repressed anger so what i do a lot
instead of using drugs i just sleep so
sleep is my drug i escape through sleep
i isolate in my apartment it just all
becomes so too overwhelming for me and
so i have therapists that are teaching
me coping skills to get away from that
to where i can utilize the gifts that
god gave me to put back out into the
community how often do you see a
therapist uh two or three times a week
i i
i got after the murders of the family i
got heavy into it for about a year and
then i just got depressed and then to
stop doing it for five years and then
just got into a heavy depression
and didn't do drugs but i would escape
into sleep and it's just until recently
that i started getting back into the
therapy
and and realizing that
to be honest i wanted to kill myself but
i don't have the balls to kill myself so
i would go out and do crazy things and
try to get other people to kill me get
into fights and try to get other people
to kill me and and when that wasn't
working god would keep telling me i have
a plan for your life you can't keep
doing this and you've done prison or
jail time uh
never never
essentially my apartment my sro is a
prison cell so yes
it is prison and you get clean from
drugs which is impressive
scott what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life how to forgive people
hands down how to forgive people and how
to serve other people is the emotion
yeah it took me till i was about 41 42
years old that i could truly forgive him
you can say you forgive people but i
truly forgive him and when i forgave him
it released a lot of energy
but there's still a struggle i didn't
talk to him for 12 years after the
murders he didn't want me to come to the
funeral nobody wanted me to come to the
funeral that really [ __ ] me up nobody
in the family told me why i couldn't
come to the funeral
so i had a lot of that to deal with
so uh
it was tough uh i i got real frustrated
i sent
very very
very
violent and and and
emails telling him i wanted to kill him
things i wanted to do to him out of this
frustration and i regret that that's not
what a christian man should do but hey
it's still on my jacket through those 12
years i didn't talk to him it was wasn't
until recently till about two or three
months ago that we reconnected he's 76
77 years old i basically had the
attitude i was going to move out here
and just [ __ ] the family i was just
gonna let them die off i was just gonna
do my own thing and be my own person but
that's no way to be the holy spirit has
convicted me to
i should go back and and just be
uh
the strongest thing
someone can do in my personal opinion in
their spiritual walk is truly love
someone that's trying to kill you
someone that has abused you
someone that has physically abused you
someone has really [ __ ] you over if
you can really go to that person and say
i love you i've been in court cases
where i see gang members kill
the sons
of
mothers that come to court and these
mothers sit there
and and and look at the gang members and
and say i truly forgive you
for what you did you murdered my son i
truly forgive you
that's not them people can't do that
because human nature by default
uh we're all [ __ ] up we're not
forgiving people we're real selfish
people you need the help of god to do
something like that
for that woman
to hug
the
the man that murdered her son in a gang
and say i truly forgive you i love you
that's the power of god intervening and
working when i can pick up the phone and
call my dad and have a conversation with
him i can feel the holy spirit coming in
just like a hit of drugs
it's a warmness over my body it's a real
it's like a hug a real loving feeling
that i get that allows me to communicate
with him where i don't
to be honest with you want to kill him
want to murder him for all the things he
did to me and my brother and my mom
growing up
all right scott thank you so much for
sharing your story thank you i wish you
the best of luck all right thank you
you